[Music]
it was a night of frustration and
questions in Iowa after people cast
their votes and the Democratic caucuses
the process of adding them up and
sending them to headquarters was plagued
with technical issues it created a
terrible image as the country watched
the first real contest of the 2020
election turned into a farce the
candidates decided to claim victory and
move on leaving Iowa and its problems
behind Bernie Sanders is looking like
the eventual winner the self-described
Democratic Socialist finished a narrow
second four years ago now he believes
he's taken a big step to securing the
Democratic nomination today marks the
beginning of the end for Donald Trump
the most dangerous president in modern
American history the biggest loser of
the night is shaping up to be former
Vice President Joe Biden for a man who
campaigned on electability it's not
clear he'll even finish in the top three
normally that would kill a campaign he
pledged to continue Elizabeth Warren
seems to have made a solid show it was
suggested the Massachusetts senator
would be competing for the same ground
with Bernie Sanders
she says the result sends a message
tonight has already showed that
Americans have a deep hunger for big
structural change it was also a good
night for the youngest candidate in the
field mayor Pete buta jet had no
problems the clearing victory by all
indications we are going on to New
Hampshire victorious for others there's
a question on how long they can sustain
their campaign though footers are
beginning to have their save on the
Republican side no technical problems
and a clear and predictable win for
president Donald Trump his two opponents
or even getting three percent of the
vote as the campaigns rolled out of Iowa
all were demanding to know what went
wrong it's not a good look for the
Democrats as a first step on the road to
the White House it's also not good news
for Iowa which is keen to retain its
first-in-the-nation status when it comes
to help picking the candidates Allen
Fisher al Jazeera des Moines